jako konfederacja chcielibyśmy
by skończyło się ręczne sterowanie przez polityków
czy ministrów
czy przez sejm
tym Jak co są wybierani sędziowie
i chcielibyśmy
i chcemy to zaproponować
by sędziów do krajowej rady sądownictwa
członków krajowej rady sądownictwa
wybierać w wyborach powszechnych
do dyskusji jest
czy połączyć to z najbliższymi wyborami ogólnopolskimi
OD biedy możemy nawet z wyborami
europejskimi to połączyć
gdybyśmy zdążyli
z wyborami prezydenckimi czy z wyborami do parlamentu
ale wybór przez obywateli z postu wśród sędziów
sędziów o dobrej reputacji
podanie ich osądowi publicznemu
to jest dużo uczciwsze rozwiązanie
niż wykluczenie kilku tysięcy sędziów
którzy byli powołani
mianowani w trakcie ostatnich 8 lat
pozbawienie ich praw obywatelskich
podzielenie ich na równych i równiejszych
doprowadzenie do pogłębienia konfliktów
i uruchomienie mechanizmu
w ramach którego politycy będą mówili Jak piład
że mają czyste ręce
bo te sędziowie wybrali tych sędziów
którzy w chwili obecnej w taki sposób
a nie inny sądzą i prowadzą swoje sprawy
wymiar sprawiedliwości
to nie jest organ samorządu zawodowego sędziów
to jest instytucja
na którą Jak obywatele powinniśmy mieć wpływ
dlatego w imieniu klubu konfederacji zwracam
wniosek o odrzucenie tego projektu w 1. czytaniu
nie chcemy pracować nad taką ustawą
która nie ma szans na wejście do porządku prawnego
a jeżeli pan panie ministrze
panie profesorze
chce poważnie porozmawiać o wymiarze sprawiedliwości
to NAS pan zaprosi
podyskutuje co myślimy
a nie prowadzi sprawę w taki sposób
że dowiadujemy się z telewizji
że jest jakiś projekt
dowiadujemy się co pan obiecał w brukseli komisarzom
a projekt na stronach sejmu
wczoraj o godzinie 19. dzień przed tą debatą zawizm
to jest skandaliczne
tak się nie da pracować nad reformami
zmianami wymiaru sprawiedliwości
będzie tylko gorzej
chyba że chcecie tylko mieszać herbatę
a ona OD tego nie stanie się wcale słodsza
co robicie dziękuję bardzo